grüß Gott meine lieben Freunde und
willkommen bei einer neuen Snapshot
Vorstellung und zwar geht es heute um
den neuen Snapshot
12W 22a heißt der glaube ich die Sonne
geht gerade auf und es gibt wieder
ziemlich viele Neuerungen viele Leute
haben dazu schon Videos gemacht habe ich
mir gedacht ach komm mach halt auch mal
ein Video damit ihr auch noch mal die
Änderung wisst es ist viel gelabert
diesmal drumrum so viel zeigen kann ich
nicht denn z.B so Sachen wie ein
dungeltempel habe ich jetzt nicht
gefunden allerdings die erste und die
geilste Neuerung finde ich es ein
stolperdaht ich zeig euch das mal Kur
ihr geht hier drüber hier wird was
aktiviert und da Hai da explodiert
gleich da ist ist mir jetzt ein bisschen
um die Ohren geflogen meine Damen und
Herren also hier ist gerade so ein
bisschen Party gewesen hier überall hier
ist ein bisschen was in der Luft
geflogen würde ich mal so grob sagen ihr
fragt euch jetzt mit Sicherheit hey was
oh Gott jetzt habe ich das ja auch alles
mit kaputt gemacht ach ich Idiot egal
jetzt fragt ihr euch mit Sicherheit e
was was war den das was hast denn Du uns
da gezeigt das zeige ich euch mal ganz
kurz indem ich das das hier noch mal
ganz kurz aufbaue wo habe ich denn wo
war das noch mal
ganz normalen Dingens brauche ich da
okay also ihr nehmt euch einfach zwei
Blöcke z.B setzt ihr hier einen Block
hin und hier und dann nehmt ihr euch
diese Trip wire Hooks heißen die also
irgendwie
stolperdahtteil Verbinder irgendwie so
die packt ihr da ein dran und da ein
dran und dann könnt ihr die so einfach
miteinander verbinden dann sind die
miteinander verbunden und wenn man hier
drüber läuft hört ihr schon dann
klatschen und diese Teile gehen dann
immer hoch und runter und dadurch wird
dann quasi was aktiviert das heißt wenn
ich dann irgendwie mit Redstone hier was
verbinde warte vielleicht kann ich das
ja auch so machen ganz einfach
momentchen mal
ich habe es noch nicht ausprobiert von
daher ist das gerade nur eine Art
Testversuch so so so warte klappt das
jetzt überhaupt ich mache das mal lieber
so
äh so
so also wenn ich jetzt hier drüber gehe
wird da dann die Fackel angezündet quasi
jetzt nicht für immer weil diese
Schaltung bleibt nur so lange aktiv
während ich hier drauf stehe wenn ich
dann halt wieder runtergehe Plop ist das
halt wieder aus aber das ermöglich halt
ganz coole Redstone Schaltungen und das
ist für Adventure Maps auch ziemlich
geil wenn man dann einfach so drüber
läuft auf einmal explodiert hinter einem
alles das ist bestimmt ganz lustig stell
also ich stell mir das ganz lustig vor
so dann die zweite Änderung ist jetzt
nicht so spielentscheidend aber halt
ganz cool und zwar von ihr kennt doch
mit Sicherheit diese Smaragde bz
Emeralds wenn man die abbaut kriegt man
ja Smaragde diese Emerald Teile wie halt
Diamanten und daraus wenn man die kann
man dann ganz normal zu solchen Blöcken
machen wie halt auch diamantblöcke oder
eisenblöcke oder goldblöcke oder was es
da nicht sonst noch alles gibt also
einfach neu Teile in so einem crafting
Dingens hier so neuen Sachen und dann
hat man daraus auch Sonnen Block so was
ihr nun seht ist ein dschungelt Tempel
und zwar habe ich da keinen gefunden ich
bin durch mehrere Dschungels
durchgeflogen da hinten war auch noch
irgendwo ein Dschungel da hinter der
Schneeregion war noch ein Dschungel da
bin ich auch noch mal hingeflogen habe
allerdings keinen gefunden ihr seht
jetzt einfach oben die ganze Zeit so ein
paar Bilder eingeblendet von diesem
Dschungel hintereinander da seht ihr
dann z.B so ein paar Gänge oder so ein
paar Fallen oder so ein paar Kisten ich
habe einfach ein paar Bilder im Internet
gesucht damit ihr seht wie der ungefähr
aussieht gefunden habe ich kein das tut
mir leid aber ich habe jetzt auch keinen
Bock gehabt 20.000 Stunden hier rum zu
suchen da beschäftige ich mich lieber
mit den wirklich wichtigen Sachen hier
also mit den meisten Sachen die dazu
gekommen sind und zwar gibt es nun auch
einen game mode 2 äh was genau der
bringt es noch relativ unklar es ist nur
klar dass es ein neuer GAM Mode ist und
dieser wird J doch noch später
verbessert bzw im Moment noch verbessert
allerdings ist hier das Zerstören von
Blöcken unmöglich ihr seht das hier ich
kann hier nichts zerstören quasi man
kann nur Sachen erkunden und das Handeln
und interagieren mit jedem Block ist
möglich was das genau heißt weiß ich
noch nicht genau aber das wird halt
genau noch verbessert und außerdem wenn
ich hier drüber laufe das funktioniert
halt alles trotzdem noch oder halt so
Sachen Tiere kann ich auch schlagen aber
ich kann halt Blöcke nicht kaputt machen
das das ist halt ganz interessant muss
man schauen was das bringt und außerdem
wenn man f drückt dafür muss man aber
nicht in diesem Modus sein dann werden
alle Chunks die um einen rum sind neu
generiert sage ich mal und zwar wenn ihr
irgendwie chunkfehler habt einfach F
drücken dann habt ihr neuen Chun quasi
also nicht ein neuen Chun sondern das
ist neu geladen so Änderung bestehen da
Features sind das Verzaubern wurde
überarbeitet müsste ihr halt alles
selbst ausprobieren ich habe nie
irgendwas verzaubert kenne mich daher
deswegen nicht aus ich bringe euch nur
die Information mal ein bisschen näher
das Maximallevel zum verzaubern würde
z.B von 50 auf 30
herabgesetzt verzaubert man mit Level 30
dann sind die Verbesserung die
Verzauberung die man dadurch halt ja
verzaubert hat den sind dann deutlich
besser und man erhält mindestens zwei
Verzauberungen geh mal bitte weg hier
außerdem bekommt man Erfahrungspunkte
wenn man jetzt auch irgendwie Erze
abbaut nicht bei Gold und Eisen sondern
irgendwie bei Diamanten oder was weiß
ich bei diesen Smaragden hier und was
war da noch
und halt auch beim Herausnehmen der
Produkte von dem Ofen oder beim Benutzen
eines Ofens und die Erfahrungspunkte
kriegt man dann halt erst nach dem
Herausnehmen von den Items so dann gibt
es ein verbessertes Creative Mode
Inventar und zwar die Tränke sind jetzt
alle nun hier in dem braunen in der
braunen Unterkategorie
der Silberfisch Pflasterstein wo haben
wir da der wurde jetzt hinzugefügt geht
das auch im Creative Mode ja geht auch
hallo du kleiner
süßer guck mal voll der coole Sound
warte
ganz lustiger Sound na ja ihr seid schon
komisch ne K mal bitte weggehen m ihr
hab echt ich geh mal bitte nach oben
so dann
außerdem
die Blabla das Survival Inventar hier
unten da könnt ihr nun auch
Rüstungsteile hier reinpacken und ihr
könnt halt jetzt auch kleine Sachen
craften und es gibt hier ein destroy
item Block bzw Feld wo ihr einfach die
Items reinziehen könnt die ihr gerade im
Inventar habt und dann werden die da
halt zerstört so wie bei too many items
dieser Mülleimer hier oben und ja das
war's dann eigentlich auch schon zum
Inventar es gab wie immer kleinere
geländeverbesserungen dass z.B hier das
alles besser angepasst wird oder
irgendwie sowas halt immer cooler man
sieht das auch schon hier am am
generieren der der Landschaften ich
gener das mal e neu voll cool guck mal
das sind küer guck mal guck mal das Kü
oh mein Gott
okay und laut einem evil Spa nun bei
Nether Portalen seltener Zombie pigments
also dass man wenn man in Nether kommt
nicht sofort von solchen Typen
geschlagen
wird die rissigen Steinziegel wo haben
wir sie wo haben wir der da die wurden
in brüchige Steinziegel
umbenannt und die Textur des Spenders
denen wir glaube ich wo haben wir den da
die wurde auch verändert ich sehe da
zwar noch keine Veränderung aber na ja
die mein halt die wurde ein bisschen
verändert und vor allem das Handel mit
Dorfbewohnern wurde ein wenig verbessert
bzw auch verändert und zwar spaw ich
immer einfach vier Leute ich kann jetzt
z.B mit dem handeln da kriege ich für 18
Sachen eine diamantrüstung also das sind
neue Items dazu gekommen und hier kann
man nun mit zwei Items Handeln außerdem
kaufen die nur auch beschriebene Bücher
wie schon gesagt man kann halt mehrere
Items tauschen und es ist möglich
verzauberte Werkzeuge zu verkaufen was
halt vorher nicht möglich war na ja dann
gab's noch die Bugfix dass unter
Redstone nun eine eingeschaltete
Redstone Fackel zu finden ist also hier
man kann nee Moment warte durch drücken
von escape wird das Spiel nun wieder
pausiert das heißt wenn ich jetzt so
drücke die Spieler bewegen sich halt
nicht mehr das war früher so wenn man
vor dem Creeper weggelaufen ist dann
kommt der hinterher und dann blablabla
und dann ist man tot obwohl man escape
gemacht hat also das war ganz
komisch und das Inventar hier im
Creative Mode lässt sich ganz normal
wieder mit E schließen außerdem wurde
der
smaragderz wird nun natürlich generiert
aber nur in diesen nur in diesen extreme
Hills Biomen das heißt in diesen Biomen
halt in diesen Landschaften wo halt
übelst hohe Berge sind nur da gibt's den
also nicht in ganz noch normalen Höhlen
so das waren erstmal die kompletten
Änderungen hier zusammengefasst ich
hoffe es hat euch wenigstens ein
bisschen gefallen ich konnte jetzt nicht
so viel zeigen aber ihr habt ja die
Bilder vom dschungeltempel gesehen aber
ich hoffe einfach mal es hat euch
gefallen ich würde mich definitiv über
einen Daumen Hoch freuen wenn ihr das
machen würdet ich zwinge euch da nicht
sondern wie immer nur eine Sache wenn
ihr wollt könnt ihr es machen wenn nicht
dann lasst ihr es einfach und ich würde
mich freuen schreibt mir doch mal in die
Kommentare fandet ihr diesen Snapshot
jetzt nötig oder fandet ihr eher so ja
komm der musste jetzt nicht unbedingt
sein oder was fandet ihr allgemein so am
geilsten ach so das hät ich auch noch
sagen können wenn diese Leute da drüber
gehen dann dann wird die Schaltung auch
aktiviert da ist mir da nämlich vorhin
ein kleines Missgeschick passiert und
zwar ist da vorher schon was explodiert
warte ich kann mal zeigen da hinten
wo haben wir da das ist schon
zugewachsen da ist dieser Typ da drüber
gelaufen über diese Schaltung das war
auch ganz interessant na ja also
schreibt mir die Sachen einfach in die
Kommentare und dann würde ich sagen
sehen wir uns beim nächsten
Vorstellungsvideo ciao